welcome to the adorable show the only
show for adorable enthusiasts my guest
today is the embodiment of all things
adorable the star of Central
Intelligence tween the rock Johnson
Duane buddy oh good to see you it's
really good to see you
we've been wanting to have you on the
show for a long time I have been waiting
for my turn to come on the adorable show
because I love all things adorable you
are kind of the king of adorable and you
are the Prince doesn't sound cute to me
I guess that's a good time to bring out
our second guest today sorry I can hey
is this cute they're both adorable in
their own odd ways - kids like mine you
know what what time it is right it's
time for the adorable where I connect
with the people Dwayne here's your
camera I want to see your most adorable
face
that's amazing
do you have a name for that one that's
called the ride thought it was called
amateur Howard why my tart I mean that's
that's not it's a good fish so in
sustainability I wanna keep ya problem
you okay maybe we can stop it now it's
time for the lullaby off each of you get
comfort needs you know kind of sing me
to sleep however you want well to get
your hours this close is part
so good night sweetheart
may all your dreams be cool twinkles not
done that thing in your back is just a
microphone hey hey there they are
do you have a go to adorable voice what
what gee gosh I love him
while we pop in the stack of pancakes my
adorable voice yeah please okay you want
you want some of the other challenges at
least things seems good in some of the
other things gee gosh mrs. McCarthy I
would love to get some butterscotch
that's a good tip butterscotch in there
though John I know I know but my was a
unicorn call well I think it's clear
it's a tie in the adorable off I'll
settle with a tie then my friend little
mug ooh is it a tie no I don't know
jeez mr. noodle last thing I wanna do
we'll get a doggie lick our adorable
king Kevin Hart okay thanks for coming
to a great you are the best since it's
the adorable show I just decided to come
with all things adorable these are my
friends this is my family
ladies and gentlemen we have our
adorable King Dwayne Johnson and
applause runner up way way in the back
it's a pleasure to be on the adorable
show and it's a pleasure to be the kid
don't be sad we got puppies everybody
have fun we've got puppies I love you I
love you more
you